[Music]
what up guys welcome back to off the
record where we talk about whatever we
want
and today's segment is ask an expert and
we have don
from a former marine raider which is
special operations
um a question i want to ask is i know a
lot of guys especially in the special
operations community
after they get out they like to
experiment with like psychedelics like
true
really yeah a lot it's like it's really
prevalent i see people pulling
it's almost like there was a
psychological impact to what they did
and they're trying to take the edge off
maybe that's just a guess why do you
think that is and do you partake in it
and
um i think that um in the military you
go through
especially special operations guys you
go through a lot of trauma yeah um
whether it's uh tbi um what's tbi
traumatic brain injury so a lot of
concussions
oh for driving over a bomb just impacts
from blast waves if you're shooting like
a rocket launcher
um and then as well as seeing a lot of
um [ __ ] up [ __ ]
yeah so that's different from ptsd right
because ptsd is more like
seeing traumatic [ __ ] yeah and we're
just starting to understand cte which is
a result of concussions
we're like a lot of athletes like
football players football players nfl
players yeah you get like
serious depression caused by like echoes
of the concussion that they had years
ago even yeah i remember shooting uh
this rocket launcher called the carl g
carl gustav it's like millimeter meter
recoil this rocket pretty much not one
of ours or someone else's
uh british oh but i was shooting it off
of a wall in afghanistan there was
uh a wall right here so i when you look
back you know how you're supposed to
check your back plus
yeah so that was clear but the wall was
still right here so i was taking all
that
concussion is that like uh uh
like the when it releases there's a wall
and it kind of bounces back
shot bounces back so you're supposed to
do it in a clear area supposed to do in
a clear area
yeah and i shot like two of them and i
was like concussed for like three days
because you get the target though yeah
but they're shooting out this wall that
didn't go down this is during training
or during like
no is that afghanistan oh [ __ ] yeah um
what kind of wall is that made out of i
want to buy that [ __ ]
it's clay cement wall i mean the it was
like a known wall that the taliban
always hid behind too
we shot like 50 cal at it i mean
everything 50 cal didn't go through
no not even that's why we shot the
rockets what the [ __ ]
yeah it hit it but it didn't take it
down dude being next to a 50 cal when he
gets shot is [ __ ] crazy
you can feel that the shockwave go
through your whole body oh yeah yeah for
sure
that's right yeah so a lot of guys
experience trauma and
head disease and so that so they're
trying to look for alternative ways
because when you get out of the military
the va just pumps you with
medication like when i got out i think i
was like on six different pills
two of them were like opiate-based for
like nightmares anxiety and all that
stuff but nobody wants to take that many
pills because it just makes you feel
numb how did you feel pretty uh with
those pills
like numb like you didn't feel nothing
yeah did you get you had nightmares and
all that stuff
yeah yeah i still do kind of but yeah
like of what happened um sometimes
um yeah just depends on the night or
whatever it was but a lot of like terror
nightmares and stuff so yeah people are
just trying to get get
over that stuff trying to get over that
stuff so psychedelics has been
um a huge answer for a lot of people
whether it's trooms or dmt
um and like shrooms like kind of create
a new neural pathway in your mind
so instead of your mind reaching the
same exact way so if you hit like a
little trigger or something
it reaps connects you back to that same
way but yeah shrooms you know like a lot
of people microdoses so they're supposed
to create new pathways
to your brain so you can create new
experiences and
that takes over what it used to take
over so that's why people use streams or
they use
dmt or ayahuasca or something like that
to really kind of
um get a different perspective on life
and the experience that that happens
because like the trigger happens again
instead of going straight to what your
original reaction or memory is it kind
of goes somewhere else
kind of go somewhere else you rewire it
huh you wire it yeah
and a lot of guys say it's like a full
reset kind of thing um
but yeah have you done dmt i have i've
done mushrooms and
dmt how many times or dmt how many times
have you done it
i'm really interested in it so the dmc
there's um two different types of dmt
that i i know of one comes from a bark
and then the other one comes from the
otak toad yeah um and then the bark ones
like a more visual
kind of experience um and then the otak
toad one is
like a extremely emotional experience do
you lick a toad so it comes from this
toad that
excretes a poison that comes off of it
when
it's like it's defense mechanism so like
scare it and then you lick it
no that when they dry out the poison
that comes off on it and they put like
little crystals and you smoke it like
out of a bong that's what my friend did
he smoked a dmd he said didn't last very
long
but he heard otherworldly beings
laughing and talking about him and then
he came back down it was very quick yeah
what was your experience like
um i was going through like a lot of
nightmares and like a lot of my own
kind of struggles and stuff like that so
one of my friends
um hooked me up with like a whole shaman
kind of experience
so um it was like in topanga of la and
then
it was like over close to the 405 like
over there was it a white guy with
dreadlocks and a tie-dye shirt do you
have to take the 10 to get to the 405
his shaman assistant had dreadlocks and
she was german
okay so we like went to like this
recovery kind of ground thing and then
um
you set your intentions on why you want
to do it so that way you can kind of
bring it out to
light and you don't have to go into
detail but it's important to
talk about it so that way you can kind
of go in there and deal with it what
were your intentions
to get rid of the nightmares and then
just to have a different perspective
on on life or the struggles that i've
been through
instead of going and be like i'm trying
to trip the [ __ ] out and have
an amazing roller coaster ride people do
that as well you know and people enjoy
it that way
um as well but what what about your
perspective
at the time did you feel like it was not
good i was just scared to do it
you know people was that your question
no like you know so you want to
take it to get a different perspective
on life what was your perspective on
life that you
feel like needed to change oh i just
felt like some of the struggles that
i've been through whether it was in the
military
or whatnot was like um
not justified kind of like
yeah i don't get too far into that one
but yeah it was like why did i have to
go through that kind of like
not like self-blame but like why do i
make that decision to do that
it's kind of regret a little bit yeah i
would say so
for sure yeah you're beating yourself up
somehow in your mind
yeah yeah and then for some of the
experience i've did overseas whether
whether it was your actions or it
happened to you or just all kinds of
whatever the reason you were beating
yourself up yeah so you set your
intentions
and then they they let you have some for
this ceremony
it was uh like a three different trip so
it was like the first one was like a
small dosage and you do that in a group
and then the second one was a bigger
dosage and you do that on your own
and then on the last one you do it in a
group is again to like kind of seal the
deal
and what you learned out of that
experience so that first one
i could feel like my body um like trying
to fight it and my mind was trying to
fight it
so i was like the the dmt trying to
fight the trip
yeah and um
i saw this like great white wolf pretty
much like
pretty much like a game of thrones wolf
that size yeah then it was like kind of
like nudging me
it's time to go like let's get out of
here or nudging you to
to go into it further but i was like oh
it's like a white wolf in my mind i was
like oh i'm not that
pure to be going with the white wolf and
then like it ran off and then this like
half gray half white wolf
came in and um i was able to jump on the
wolf and i was like going through this
vortex that's
tiny the white one is like no that one's
too clean
and then one with the eye patch is like
with a scar he goes yeah that's my homie
right there
oh you know you're so do you know how
are you so
deep into it where it seems like reality
and you don't
and you know once you're out of the trip
you're like oh [ __ ] i was tripping
or you're self-aware that you're
tripping during the trip
okay um you're not aware it's like a
full out-of-body full immersion you're
just like oh [ __ ] there's a [ __ ] wolf
right now
yeah like how do you remember after the
trip you remember
that like what you went through yeah and
to be honest like a lot of it
is unexplainable um okay so
i did that trip on mond on monday but i
forgot on friday
um when my friend took me to one of his
shamans again and
they tried to put me through like a
precursor because they knew i was kind
of scared of it
but that day we just did the bark um
kind of dmt trip and then it was
i remember like seeing a whole bunch of
visuals and i see like a few faces and
stuff like that like cartoon faces no
one i knew
and then like a lot of weird patterns
and stuff like that but the entire time
there was this like black
void coming up the entire time like
crepping up as like
more i went and i kept seeing these
visuals and i kept creeping up
and then they were like right to the
very top and i was like scared
you know because i was like what am i
not ready to deal with whatever that was
and then that's why i was so reluctant
on the monday to like kind of dive into
it
but you're still jumping on a wolf's
back i think it's pretty good yeah so
then
you come you kind of come out of it and
then you're still a little disoriented
um and then you go into the second trip
and that one was like a
blast off you mean you you come out of
it as in you sober up yeah so you went
on the wolf's back and you guys just
[ __ ] ran through the jungle or
whatever do a vortex
yeah through a vortex and then you don't
remember what happened in there
and then you know that that was it like
that was that was going through the
vortex and i
opened my eyes you don't fully like
you're not like
tripping and sober you're like tripping
kind of tripping tripping tripping
this episode of off the record is
brought to you by feels
so i just recently started trying cbd i
never really had to before because you
know that i knock out really really fast
but these days i've been working out at
night and you know i get that adrenaline
and i take the pre-workout so i'm
freaking amped and i'm laying in bed
i'm like oh shoot it's like 12 o'clock
now and i still haven't knocked out
so i tried cbd the other day shout outs
to feels and it actually mellowed me out
it was cool that it was awesome that's
what i've been telling you
it was cool i was able to kind of like
chill out a little bit and i was like oh
dang like i actually feel warm and it'll
feel a little bit sleepy
and i knocked out even while taking
pre-workout just a few hours before
so i really like it and for those of you
guys who also have
anxiety or high stress levels and have
sleeplessness
give feels a try because it could
definitely reduce those symptoms
yeah man it makes me feel like the feels
yeah and then i'm like yo it's time to
chills
and it's pretty cool because it's super
easy to take you just get like a couple
of drops put it under your tongue and
you're ready to go
um each individual though has different
tolerance levels
so you know you might be a lightweight
like me where you just need a few
or you might need a whole shot glass but
i do not recommend it
always ask a professional i started
small and that's what's cool about the
professional part
they offer real human support too so if
you're like what do i do
i got this one homie telling me this
instead of the homie telling me that
well you could talk to a professional
they'll tell you
what to take for me i just wanted to
start off small because i wanted to like
you know eat baby step into it so i only
took two drops yeah and the thing that i
was scared of
is like the hangover or some kind of
weird
like you know addiction or after effects
but
actually doesn't have any of that and
it's just a natural way to chill out
yeah
and it's super cool because you can sign
up to the community and then they can
deliver right to your door
every single month so if you need to use
it on the regular basis
it takes the guesswork out of it and for
this membership you could
cancel or pause it anytime you want it's
just a stress-free way of getting
something delivered
feels has me feeling my best and it can
help you
too become a member today by going to
feels.com
off to record and get 50 off your first
order
plus free shipping that's f e a
l s dot com slash off the record to
become a member and to get
automatically 50 off your first order
plus
free shipping dude why are you waiting
go
or do that you know one more time that's
fuels.com
off the record but this next time you
blast off where do you go
dude that one was like the most intense
experience i've ever been through like i
don't really know how to explain it but
was it like your yeah your body's full
of penises and everyone's gonna blow job
everywhere
i don't know no not like that that
sounds kind of cool
you're like oh i'm coming everywhere
um but yeah i saw my my dad my dad
passed away last
last year like a year ago he came to you
uh he didn't come to me it was like
he was already there yeah and then i saw
my friends that passed away like jeremy
i was talking about my friend mike
um and i didn't have a conversation with
them it was like were they just doing
their own thing they were just doing
their own thing i was able to see him
where were you like my dad was uh like
drinking beers and stuff with his
friends you know like that's what he
liked to do
my friend jeremy was playing the guitar
you know i saw him and
i knew that they were in a happier place
and i always tripped out about like
what happened with jeremy i was checking
out what happened with my friend mike in
afghanistan when we lost him like just
those scenarios
and the biggest experience like to let
go
you know because in your lives you're
like so tense up
all the time and in that experience you
have no choice but
to just let go of everything that you're
seeing everything that the energy that's
flowing through you it's
yeah it was life-changing for sure and
how how long was that
experience you completely lose
perception of time and
reality-ish too i think it was maybe
like 30 minutes
or something like that oh no one's like
timing you know no one's telling me is
it like inception where it feels like a
month and then it was just like 30
minutes
yeah i don't even know i couldn't even
really put like a time to it
when you were there like how many days
were you there at this
like the trip center like a four-hour
session kind of thing oh that's
four hours you tripped three times yeah
so take me through the whole last trip
the mind-blowing trip you see your dad
you see your friends like
anything else i honestly don't even know
how to explain it but
um i remember laughing my ass off
you know like just joy and then i also
remember like
balling my eyes out like crying trying
to like let go of all the
tense [ __ ] bad stuff in my mind
um like like i opened my eyes like to
kind of come back to reality a little
bit and it wasn't the real world so
you're opening your eyes and you're in
the room but it's not
what you remember it's like different
what do you see like
these weird like circular shapes coming
up
like bright lights bouncing off and out
and like
i see like a bright one in the middle um
so dmt is like a like a natural chemical
that's already in our bodies
so the reason that the otak one is a lot
more
um emotional is because it comes from a
biological
animal instead of the plant right so
your body connects to that one a little
bit more but
that's what releases when your brain
when you dream and as well as
like right before you die it like dumps
your dmt that's why some people see like
the white light at the end of the tunnel
and i felt like i was seeing the white
light for a second
i was like oh [ __ ] am i like dying or
whatnot but it was like i was just going
through and breaking through like
another
dimension and then it kept going you
know so it was
it was crazy but the biggest lesson out
of it was like hey it's okay
during your personal trip or doing a
personal one by yourself
it was a shaman or something yeah so
it's like the shaman leads you through
it and
they're playing like into you the whole
time they're not talking to you they're
playing like these sound bowls
um there's meditation wow insane yeah
and then uh
they sprayed me with like water to make
sure i was like cool enough
it was like a hole cause you can
overheat or something i don't know
it's just like a warmer day yeah but
like after
the trip they bring out this like big
plate of fruit and chocolate
and they make you fast before so like i
guess the effects hit you a little bit
more
but you just like and they have the
brook stone
chocolate covered acai berries
right wait you know what i'm talking
about what side no it's just funny that
it's like that's hilarious
you think like these like hippie guys
they got their whatever but they're like
wait that sees candy
yeah yeah that's so good though it's
like a south american papaya and it's
like
yeah it was so good but um yes and then
after that one
um everyone does it in that circle it's
me and my friend and then
um this um one of our friends that's a
female she was there kind of going
through her own stuff too
and then the last one you do as a group
again to kind of like seal the deal and
make sure
that you learn something was the last
one just as intense as the second one
no it was the least intense probably
because your body has
used to it a little you see it already
so the last one
were you like aware like you're they
they tell you to keep your eyes
open to be aware so that way the things
that you've seen and things that you
kind of
experience in that that you can
integrate it because it's always about
the integration piece right like
you can't just do it for fun and then
not take anything you learn from it so
when you were in your roller coaster
ride
were your eyes closed or like what do
you mean by keeping your eyes open
yeah if you close your eyes the effects
are i think stronger because you're not
influenced by the things that you see
outside when you open your eyes you're
still in the journey or whatever it is
but you're
oh you have some type of perception of
things like you could control that like
you like
open now or like well they tell you like
if it's too much
then try to open it but what was the
third trip it was just like
i was trying to keep my eyes open so
just like a lot of reintegration
like i could see energy flow through
like the trees and
the people around me do you feel like at
the end
um you were able to change your
perspective
for like a month after i was like the
happiest guy for sure
um able to focus better and stuff like
that but
of course like drinking alcohol and
stuff like that rebrings like the
depressants and
stuff like that back so i redid another
trip um to kind of like
like the alcohol reverses the effects of
it not reverse but
like alcohol is like it's a bad habit
you know like yeah drinking too much
yeah and
it puts your mind in this the present
state it's a depressant so it can drive
a lot back to those emotions
again so you have to integrate like you
have to learn something from that and
like hey stay away from things that
are gonna bring negative energy to your
life and [ __ ] like that so
you have to do it again i did it again
with one of my other friends i wanted to
do it but
that main focus for me was hey to stop
drinking so much
and then um to able to accept other
people more for who they are
in any roles around me so instead of
like just
because in the military like oh you just
suck or you're
good yeah you know but now in civilian
world it's like hey it's important
everyone sucks yeah and everybody has a
weakness and if it's they're not the
right fit for your company or they're
not the right fit for
you as like a partner or whatever it is
then it's okay to let them go
as well but i think like that's the
biggest
difficulty i see like from military guys
in civilian world is like the military
guys there's like no
time for emotions almost like it's like
just [ __ ] do it right you're talking
yeah you're taught that so so you since
you had to deal with it you think
normal people should be stronger or
whatever and then when you integrate
back into civilian
world there's so many of these like
other things that come off very petty
kind of like kind of like um you know
things that are unnecessary in the
battlefield or whatever that wastes time
right it's like you're gonna kill people
you're gonna get people
dead in the military if you're just like
wait
but i have second thoughts yes right but
then in the civilian world it's like we
have that luxury to be like
uh you know what i'm kind of having you
know i'm not feeling it right now or
like
it's different it's not life or death so
i think that's the biggest
difference i see from like veterans or
guys coming back into the world
and seeing like the [ __ ] that they have
to deal with it's like oh dude that's
that's a huge difference in culture for
sure and and the culture
like the veteran culture is not very
inducive of like hey
transitioning back into the real world
you know because
we should be more understanding of what
they've went through and and everybody
go through
an experience in a different trauma
level like
if they drove one bomb that could be way
more traumatizing than anything i went
through when i was in the military and
i can't really determine that but a lot
of guys in the military like
oh you didn't do [ __ ] in the military
you know you got shot at one time you
didn't kill anybody or whatever it is
like they're just judging each other a
lot and i feel like
that's a huge downside of what america
and
especially the veteran community is
really about we should be more open to
helping other people out because
everybody goes to their own struggle
well my brother just sat in a [ __ ]
chair in the air force so he really
didn't do [ __ ] in there he was a pilot
no he was an air traffic controller oh
[ __ ] no those are awesome guys
no they're fine but he never even left
the states okay he's just chilling now
yeah we should give him all this [ __ ]
then dude [ __ ] that guy dude so much
[ __ ]
that's pretty crazy man damn what made
you want to do
uh psychedelics out of nowhere like was
it a thing that your friends were like
we gotta you gotta do this [ __ ] man i
mean i've had a lot of friends do
for the longest time i've just been
scared you know like i don't wanna
did you see like good results that's why
that's you made you more inclined to do
it
i mean like your friend earlier was
saying as well as like it's all about
that reintegration piece right if
you do something you learn something and
you don't ever apply it or you don't
ever
use it then it's a waste right so it's
the exact same process but i
it's definitely been better because i've
done a lot of acid but i'm so scared of
doing shrooms in
ayahuasca acid's way more intense that's
what i heard but then now
because i thought shrooms was scarier
like my friend was like
yeah man i turned into a [ __ ] sponge
when i was taking a shower
and then like the water was filling me
up and i was so scared i was falling
about
he's gonna wring himself out and then
when i heard that i was like
oh [ __ ] that i'ma stick with acid and
then
that's what i heard is that acid is more
intense but i'm still scared of shrooms
and ayahuasca and dmt
and stuff i don't want to turn into a
sponge either that sounds like [ __ ] i
don't like that
well i've read a little bit research on
alaska but i was makes you like purge
yeah puke and yeah but it's still dmt
right when they combine the two plants
that are
from completely different places of the
country and like
that's kind of crazy right but i heard
ayahuasca last like 10 hours or some
outrageous
i don't know how long it lasts but i
don't want to throw up if i'm tripping
yeah what is uh the dmt is smokable yeah
you hit it out of a bomb what's the
other one
the other dmt yeah the other yeah so
both the toad and the bark is
out of the bomb out of a bomb do they
last
long like how long does it really last
because my friend who did the smokeable
one he said that it was like only
minutes
i would say it's about like 20 to 45
minutes if i could put a time
i'm down yeah [ __ ] yeah i'm not gonna do
hours man that's what scares me about
shrooms too
maybe i'll micro dose but like people
are like yeah you got to get it ready
for a six
hour trip man yeah that's a lot that's
happy dude i'm like
what about it wonderful acid though it's
an asset of a really long i haven't done
it since high school
but it was it was hours yeah but i
scored for anything yeah
in high school you're trying to prolong
it and be in dream world for 12 hours
straight you know so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you